cet infirmier se prête à passer une
longue nuit une autre au front de la
pandémie à el paso
il est épuisé inquiet le pire durant le
temps des fêtes avec les réunions
familiales propice à la propagation de
la maladie au moment où ils manquent de
matériel de personnel assure-t-il oui
oui car sinon on ne tiendra pas oui les
gens veulent se retrouver
ce n'est pas le bon moment pour célébrer
mon style
banks pv le nombre de contaminations a
grimpé à el paso après le long congé de
la fête du travail
les hospitalisations aussi pratiquement
la moitié des lits sont occupés par des
patients de lakovic 19
des centaines d'entre eux sont aux soins
intensifs
il a fallu aménager un hôpital dans le
centre des congrès c'est là que l'on
commence tout juste à administrer un
nouveau médicament le bam la navy mahb
aux patients les moins atteints el paso
ville majoritairement hispanophones la
pauvreté est l'un des facteurs qui
contribuent elles à forte propagation du
virus
le tiers des résidents n'a pas de
couverture santé et repousse donc le
moment d'aller consulter ce journaliste
nous explique qu'il ya de tels cas même
dans sa famille bien souvent ajoutent
ils sigean se retrouvent aux urgences
pour tenter de freiner la pandémie un
couvre-feu est en vigueur la nuit à el
paso pour quelques jours le plus haut
responsable du comté avait déjà imposé
une mesure plus strictes en fermant les
commerces non essentiels mais il a été
débouté en cour à la demande de gens
d'affaires par des procureurs et des
élus républicains
une décision qui a indigné le corps
infirmier le gouverneur républicain
opposé à un nouveau confinement au texas
rappelle qu'il est dépêchée de l'aide et
du personnel médical
el paso tout comme le fédéral des
camions réfrigérés viennent en renfort
aux morgues débordé et la garde
nationale à prend le relais de
prisonniers mobilisés pour transporter
les dépouilles
on dénombre plus de 900 décès depuis le
début de la pandémie
voir ces militaires débarquer dans sa
ville ébranle crise babcock
pas de répit pourrait pas sot récemment
secoué par une crise des migrants venus
du mexique et par une fusillade dans un
walmart le tueur visaient des latinos la
pandémie nous frappe de plein fouet dit
il tout le monde est touché
alors que l'on commençait tout juste à
se relever ici libéraux radio canada el
paso au texas